police cars all over the place marks
memory of rifles boom just a door just
flies off the hinges hands above your
head don't move get on the [ __ ]
ground now and similar to your saying
with Takashi because he got fifth line
yeah there's a lot of people on YouTube
right now talking about to Kashi I'll
have no idea what they're talking about
even the hip-hop channels 50% of the
prisoners today are in because of drug
charges that's what changed the war
against drugs when you were in did you
see some guys were like that just
doesn't belong in here you know justice
system is a business model if you go to
trial it costs the state hundreds of
thousands millions they want everyone to
sign a plea bargain and go over to the
prison system just about down if
everybody exercised the right to trial
the system would collapse it couldn't
afford to do all the trials you're going
to prison
how was Ella you sit in the wrong place
it's all over I was at the point where I
was about to kill myself in the jail he
got so rough it's one of the lowest
points of my life so today we have an
interesting guest with us Sean at were
just to kind of give you a little bit of
background about him they call him the
ecstasy kingpin they called him at one
point the Bank of England he sold a lot
of ecstasy in Arizona I know why are we
talking about ecstasy today on value
taemin he was deported from the state's
December of oh he has not been there
since but his business operation was 200
employees reporting to him at one point
and ranted like a real company back in
the days when he was doing this in
Arizona for four years and so I'm
excited about taking a different angle
with them because a part of it we're
going to talk about his dealings with
Sammy the bull Gravano Mexican Mafia you
know what it is to be in prison how do
you kind of position yourself when you
go in but also at the same time I want
to talk about some of the you know rates
of people going back into prison where
some people can do to avoid making bad
decision for that to ever happen and
when you do come out what can you do to
never go back and so having said that
Shaun Atwood thanks for being with us in
rally time it's a pleasure Patrick great
to see you here yes and your story is
very interesting I got to tell you thank
you so walk us through before you became
you know you got into this world who was
Shaun Atwood in high school decades
before bumping heads with summing the
ball as a teenager in this country
didn't grow up with much money but when
I chose economics in my high school only
six of us chose it the teacher saw had
an aptitude for it he started giving me
classes on my own explaining the
financial times all the numbers how the
stock market works then when I was 16 I
went through my dad's for money to
invest he told me to bugger off
I hit my nan up and she gave me fifty
pounds like just under hundred dollars
and I doubled it first they have
dealings on British Telecom sure so I
was hooked at 16 at 16 Wow telling all
the mates in my little town I'm gonna go
to America I make a million fly all you
guys over that was my dream so from
there on so at what point did you make
it to the States
okay so I went off to college did a
levels did Business Studies that you
need and then headed out to Arizona
because I used to visit my answer as a
kid and it really dazzled me the
lifestyle in Arizona Arizona desert I've
come from a little chemical
manufacturing town in the northwest that
makes sense planes coming in you see the
swimming pools in the back yeah let me
ask you personality-wise high school
were you were you the good grade were
you the good kid were you the popular
kid that you date the hottest girl you
the enemy I was getting beat up by the
rugby players I was one last to grow in
size I had anxiety
I almost got beat to death by some
drunks and that compounded my anxiety so
when I went out to clubs and stuff I
wasn't dance it was too self-conscious I
had this shyness when the rave scene
began
I took ecstasy wouldn't stop dancing all
night long won't stop making friends
with strangers and that became my crutch
over ten years for over ten years I'm
doing drugs people seen this wild and
crazy party animal but I was
self-medicating for PTSD from almost
getting beat to death by these drugs
unbelievable yeah and how did you get
introduced to it the first time was it
just you went to a club yeah in this
country in the 1980s to get in the club
you had to dress in a suit and tie and
it was very snotty like snooty they
wouldn't let you in the bouncers if you
weren't dressed right the kids were sick
of it they started breaking into
warehouses breaking into airplane
hangars we're in all this call of
clothing and taking ecstasy and you
dancing all night long at these illegal
party so it was like a revolution in
music it was suits back into these
corner nightclubs yeah in the 80s and
the kids were sick of you know you get
to line up and the bouncers would look
at you and if you're not dressed right
you're not getting in so this week so we
were like you know f that we're just
gonna start doing our own thing
breaking into warehouses airplane
hangars we're in all these psychedelic
colors baggy jeans British Knight
sneakers this is what you're this is
what you would you say this is Lady this
is late eighties early nineties cuz I
went to Arizona in 91 what happens when
you go to Arizona I know you got into
the stock market yourself how did that
happen free so I arrived in Arizona as
an illegal alien got no worries alien
yeah okay just got my student credit
cards so I'm now in a race against
running out of money on my student
credit cards to make money join a
brokerage and quickly learn it's
commission only they sell them you've
got to do these classes for months to
get my Series seven I said I haven't got
time to do the classes for the series
seven put me in for it right now
and then they said well alright we'll
take a chance and he was like the guy
running it was like a mafia mafia kind
of guy his mannerisms and I think they
were hooked into the Mafia this this
penny stock outfit was that I just got
my that's how I got my foot in the door
any stack smile and dial mirrors on your
quad you got to be pacing with a 25-foot
curly cord cuz pacing smiling brokers
make more sales you're only as big as
your numbers the rap on the board for
the month exactly like wolf of Wall
Street and that's the world you came out
of I was it was a baptism of fire I
quickly realized what they were doing so
talking about power moves me and another
rookie broker we realized these guys
were just putting people in chop stocks
we got some newspaper articles about
them photocopied the entire accounts
from the entire brokerage was sneaking
at night for copying all the accounts we
jump ship to a more stable outfit and
took all these accounts with us and so
what happened then
well they were threatening to big the
guy the past you know he was the threats
were getting issued and we went out and
bought guns
to blow up my partner's car some of
these guys yeah I mean it's a
competitive world if I'm late at night
getting all the fouls the clients in you
Colin with another place yeah well
you're still doing penny stocks no no
when we moved we we saw what that those
guys were doing so then we will I
actually trying to make our clients
money by putting them in the stocks like
Motorola would had the brick cell phone
yes Intel so how what did you do people
wanted to do high-risk investments
taking these clients over from the penny
stock world so what I looked at was
America West Airlines junk bonds mm-hmm
they were trading 10 cents on the dollar
and they went back up to par yeah so I
did really well on them didn't sell them
at par but sold 100% return multirole
was another good one because of the BRIC
cellphone they were doing great as well
they were going up consistently and so
the point where my commissions
I was grossed in half a million dollars
a year in Commission five years then I
was the top guy in the office I had
enough money to retire from it but I was
dying to get back into the party scene
and I was thinking do I want to go in
the rat race and get up at 6:00 you know
5:00 in the morning six [ __ ] money
sales meeting or just make money from
the party scene and that that that
excitement and greed took over first off
which Biddy were you part of what was
the broker-dealer dude there was various
ones over the years and the last one was
Joseph Charles was cleaning for
birthstones
got it yeah were you ever with a Morgan
Merrill were you ever with Merrill
offered me a hundred grand to move over
to them and cuz they wouldn't let me
sell short shares and they wouldn't let
that but they wants me to buy their
proprietary companies I refused how did
you get into the world where you said
what if I start selling what was that
accidental was it intentional how did
that take place the rave scene has such
a big impact on me in this country one
of the goals I set was when I make a
million America I'm gonna transfer that
scene over to the Sonoran Desert and in
the beginning I am just buying pills cuz
I've got so much money and showing off
or giving them away to my friends this
is the transition point now where I'm
still in the stock market as a broker
but then I'm seeing you know when you
give away drugs for free you attract a
lot of friends and then I'm doing the
business potential of it the local
dealers could only supply you know up to
100 pills at a time found out they were
getting them out of LA so far as an
experiment
I'll buy files and pills see how long it
takes to get rid of these they have a
gun in a weekend yeah at thousand and a
weekend yeah so what were you buying
them a delay for alright so this is
before I really knew yes acknowledged
so in LA in the beginning my first
transaction was probably I don't know
around $12 for a thousand pills and they
were going for 25 to 30 dollars in the
clubs so you're to X in them immediately
yeah so now are you were you selling it
yourself were you move into tau or will
you have another guys where you sell at
16 you know I make the four on and how
I'm talking right off the bat not to
become a business right off the bat I've
got my business partner bodyguard with
me wild man this huge guy from my
hometown
he's like my muscle and we're in an
apartment he's in he's moved into with
summer people and we throwing these
parties every weekend and that was when
we brought those thousand pills back and
we just sold them all out through that
party so you and you and another person
saw the thousand and yeah people were
coming and they jumped by like 50 or 100
at a time and they just take them off to
another party yeah and it just went
throughout the weekend so 12 25 to 30
you buy for 12 you sold for 25 to 30 so
what did that we can do to you well not
all I would say 125 says if someone buys
a hundred I'm giving them a deal sure of
course well you know I'm seeing this
fast almost doubling of my money and I'm
thinking I can just be doing this
kicking back having the time of my life
you know just hanging out with wild and
crazy night people or working all these
long hours and I sacrifice my slow and
steady progress how quickly was your
transition away from production you know
how was it like was it immediate you
were like I'm I can't even be seen
myself doing it was a like a three to
six month process I was having so much
fun and then going into the office so
burnt out because of all the drugs I was
doing I was doing up to 20 hits of
ecstasy on the weekend and throwing
other drugs in the mix even taking the
xanax didn't recover me properly I was
getting so burnt out cuz of all the
pills and the long hours I needed to
sleep after the partying the transition
was quite fast
so what's fast one week two weeks a
month was it like well numb before you
Deportes isn't banned for being a menace
to society was in the country for a
couple of months I was during that what
during his visit was my transition a
couple of months couple months kinda so
you leave the Biddy you're not doing
anything anymore what are they saying
what are they thinking about you being
gone
do you know what you're doing or not yet
I'm sure some of the guys were partying
with you so it was such a big deal for
me to just to go from one to the other
I didn't even tell them and my parents
actually called the brokerage and asked
where I was and they said they'd heard
I've been my car was found burnt out in
Mexico caused this panic amongst my
family from being in this legitimate
person to going into this criminal
underworld I didn't know how to you know
what to say to the the BD people so I
just as a ceased and occasion yeah we're
there any signs in high school of you
doing a creative activities where
somebody would say I think one day he's
probably gonna be doing something or
like you were doing during lunch hour I
would run to the corner shop buy sweets
like / drops and strawberry bonbons and
run back to the school and sell them for
double the price and it also get like
dinner coupons for them as well and get
my dinner with the dinner coop yes so
sells you've been selling for a while
always that a natural sales personality
yeah got it
even in high school so you even ice
cover the entrepreneur budding
entrepreneur did so wholesale to retail
so so now you have this weekend you tell
yourself I spent $12,000 about a
thousand pills you know I'm coming back
turning these for 25 to 30 or somebody
buys 100 wholesale say 20 bucks this was
the easiest ten grand I made in a
weekend with your body your you know
bodyguard you know your security from
there you what do you thinking next okay
I can scale it how soon did you start
expanding to hold the phone level we
were getting them out of LA for a year
or two and my demand in Arizona now is
so high these guys out of LA can only
provide five thousand pills at a time so
I figure out they're getting them out of
Holland so I can't leave the country
I start selling people over to Holland
with testing kits you could buy from a
website called dance safe
an ecstasy pill should be one hundred
hundred twenty-five milligrams of MDMA
and clay usually like a beige color or a
faded color often the pills that have
got artificial stuff in them are colored
but sometimes the color can just be food
dye but the color is often a heads up
and I was cognizant that if I'm selling
tens of thousands of pills
someone could potentially die it's
extremely rare but it's usually when
there's a bad ingredient so my people
took these testing kits and it changes
it was like a blue purple color so
nobody ever died after pills and they
brought back such a pure product I was
getting you know known as English sean's
pills the Bank of England's pills it got
to the point where the competition with
their colored pills were saying you know
these are English sean's
they were trying to capitalize on my
brand lashauwn's yeah yeah so what was
your a Vegas order you got from Holland
biggest audio was 40,000 hits someone
smuggling mission yeah and this was
before 9/11 so don't try this at home if
anyone's watching this but back then you
could just put thousands of pills into
your luggage in pillowcases or in
screwed into computer towers and get on
a plane I had one woman she got on a
plane with pills in vitamin jars landed
at Sky Harbor Airport got stopped
customs took her into a room opened the
luggage put the pills on a table and
said what are they
and she goes vitamins and they said cool
put them back in the luggage just said
ha have a nice day
yeah and believable yeah at the 40,000
mark how much are you paying for them at
that point at a peak of this now in the
late 90s my organization is structured
like a corporation so we've got heads of
each faction under me which vary from 10
to 20 depending upon what's going on at
that point in time so I've got 10 to 20
different factions over time so I'm
fronting out now the heads of the
organization up to five thousand at a
time maybe at ten dollars or maybe eight
dollars to kind of
with that person they then front them
out to their middle people at 15 or 20
depending on how much they take and then
they get sold into the clubs and to the
raves at 25 to 30 so if I am bringing in
40,000 at $3 our last $2 gotta add in
all that all the smuggling cost the
transport costs and the legal costs as
well so if I'm bringing him in let's say
no more than $3 and I'm getting 40,000
front of them out at 10 quarter of a
million quarter million per 40 yeah and
how much what do you remember what you
were moving per month was it the ideas
like what's your peak month
so it was sporadic we had quarter of a
million months only like every I don't
know every two or three months something
like that but over time it was four
years I was doing this so added double I
wasn't dealing as many as fast as Sammy
the bull
but like the Tempe Police said over time
it was more than he dealt you ran for
four years I think he ran for a year and
a half so you sold more than Sammy the
bull and at the time he was also in
Arizona
yes did you guys ever face-off did you
ever have a sit-down with her and any
meeting like the heats is seen in the
movie were Pacino and then he was
sitting on top I locked down the Arizona
rave scene because I was an early
entrant and it was a lot of competing
little cliques those little cliques
would come to me as the Bank of England
to lend money for the parties and the
drug deals whatever now some of those
little cliques had disputes so me and
wild man would mediate those disputes
and you know in the end we incorporated
all these different little cliques into
my organization so I had the local
people locked down all of a sudden these
new kind of ecstasy dealer started
showing up in the club scene at the
raves
like steroid head jocks he had the
devil's dogs these white supremists I
think there are may sir or Chandler
these these big dudes and I'm like you
know who are these guys stepping on my
toes so we're all getting really curious
because we had no idea where they were
coming from now I was married to a woman
she'd done a university degree but she
was also doing lesbian internet porn
she had a bisexual lover a female and
she said look you knew what yeah yeah
yeah that
I encouraged and she said look her
girlfriend's boyfriend is one of these
new dudes and he wants to meet you and
discuss business opportunities so I
still don't know who they work for so I
take one of my bouncers with me Rosetti
he's packing the gun to this nightclub
my wife and we got her and Rosetti hangs
back with the gun they don't know he's
with me this is the guy the Spaniard
comes out and goes you come into that
you know the VIP room I want you to meet
my business partner I go back there on
my own
Rosetti slipped back this way he's
watching me and then this massive you
know six foot six now four plus guy
comes out I'm sat down on the sofa
between these two guys you're sitting
between the big guy stole everyone's ass
offices to get out of the the the area
reeling and leave the room
and we sit down on this sofa like I said
early arm you know I'm taking drugs
because it makes me wild but inside I'm
the shy anxious person person why I took
GHB going in and the GHB is hitting me
when we're on when we're sitting down on
the sofa and I introduce me this is the
Spaniard and the other guy mark I think
the other guy's name was so I just
playfully grabbed these guys I gotta
show them a bit of a crazy mofo so I
grab the knees and you know they were
like it was a bit crazy and they were
like look Shawn we're moving a lot of
pills and we know you are and we know
you look down with the local people
you've got a good relationship with them
how would you feel about moving pills
our pills will give you a good price
and I said lot and where are you guys
these pills did those colored pills I'm
getting pills from Holland I've got a
reputation to uphold
I'm not gonna mess around with these
cold pills a lot of them Calif it's made
in America
so the Spaniard he was he was okay with
whatever he was calm but the other guy
he was like how
you know how do you think you are
disrespecting our pills one call to
Sammy the ball and we can have you taken
out to the desert
now the word of John Gotti and all that
making you know news and I'm thinking
these guys just talking [ __ ] what at
this point have you heard it a name
Sammy the bull yet like a John Gotti new
on the news but no I'm talking local
Arizona that he's gone up against you so
you haven't heard Sammy boy but maybe
these guys are plastic gangsters
throwing this name how trigger me got it
but when I got out and saw my bouncer
he's like but you know hey you know this
is this is serious now if it is the ball
because I'm he's murdered up to two
dozen people who so I'm I'm high on GHB
and this is starting to sink in a bit as
we're going out of there so how did that
end how did that end with them alright
so it didn't end well because I told him
law I'm staying with my people and doing
my own product
there's enough room for us to coexist
but I will give you guys a heads up
since you guys have been running around
in the clubs in the rave saying you the
biggest drug kingpins since you know
whatever a lot of heat is starts come to
the scene me and my security people are
noticing undercover cars with cameras
taking pictures please coming in
pretending to be from out of town trying
to set up ecstasy deals nothing like
this was going on before you guys came
into town so they were like alright well
Spaniard was like okay well thanks for
the heads up
and I said look it's not each other
we've got to worry about its the cops
eventually that about proved accurate so
let me ask you at this point you said
you you went four years he went a year
and a half yeah at what party or four
was it that he got in 9899 around then
that those guys started popping up into
the scene ninety nine is when they
started popping up in the scene I'm
guessing okay
I'm guessing got it so you're you you've
been going for a year year and a half
while they pop up in the scene yeah okay
so you never had a faceoff directly with
Sammy there was no what happen was well
I was getting protected by the New
Mexican Mafia so I felt a fair degree of
safety because even those guys coming
into town the New Mexican Mafia were
formidable I mean these guys have got a
lot of heavy duty
no I'm thinking these guys have got my
back they're more powerful than these
guys the drugs is telling me now you be
comparatively safe but what happened was
my bouncer when we left at me said how
long will the peace last if this is real
for real
they lured my top sales guy Skinner who
was moving a lot of product for me to a
nightclub in Scottsdale under the
pretenses of buying pills from him took
him into the men's room knocked his
teeth out knock took tens of thousands
of dollars off him
that was the heads up that things were
getting heavy yeah I moved to Tucson
after that how strong were you at this
point meaning how deep were you at this
point not deep of movers deep of
strength power street cred you know
enough gangs on your side or the right
muscle on your side that people don't
want to cross you my philosophy always
was if this goes to the violence or
murder level it's a whole new ballgame
the police are gonna look at us
differently and then we're gonna get
sent down for a lot of time yeah I've
got the New Mexican Mafia behind me but
utilizing that is going to cause me even
bigger problems in the long run just the
fact that they're behind mean people
know there's enough of a deterrent to
give me that street crap and keep the
debts getting paid so I moved over 100
by 100 miles or so away to Tucson in a
million-dollar house on a mountain and
the gated guarded community sin Bacchus
well you couldn't even get into that
neighborhood without going through a
guard you had to call a House bill
banana was up and further along the
mountain range was paul mccartney very
familiar with that area yes almost
beautiful place you some want to live
that's where the people do son it's like
a dream how it goes to the mailbox and
there would be deer around the mailbox
the Lightning would bounce down the
mountain up a house and when there was
the rain a waterfall would fall beside
the house and a little stream of it's
amazing so at this point what what do
you you buy yourself no one's around
your wife's not around your muscles not
around your friends are not around the
party scenes not around
your wife's girlfriends not around no
one's around you by yourself what are
you telling yourself how are you telling
yourself
Sean you're in too deep you got to
figure out a way to get out or are you
saying let's double down
go to another state what are you
thinking I am thinking I'm safe now into
some I've got a right hand man who I
trust with my life or no or take a
bullet for me Cody Bates he's dead now
he was doing the rounds of Phoenix he
had rented apartment out just for the
cash only me and him knew where it was
so I don't even have to leave the house
now everything's just running
automatically while these guys are doing
whatever they're doing in Phoenix so I'm
just trying to enjoy the money doing all
this crazy stuff I've still got my
security team a bouncers but what
happened there was a challenge to my
dominance let's say when there was a
situation whereby my wife went on a
mission with one of my guys and they
ended up sleeping together yes what
happened there so we had to set an
example
and to make sure everybody wasn't trying
to overthrow me because even my guy
Skinner now who was my top sales guy he
was smoking Sherm and crystal meth and
crack and cuz I had moved out of Phoenix
power-play now he's thinking he's going
to take over my business with they
suffer one of my security guys and
they're spreading words that I'm going
down and that they're going to be taking
over and that my people needed to work
for them so we have to get that in check
what does that mean I can't comment any
further okay yeah I got it so Cody Cody
was Cody or Debates
right Cole Debates did he he's no longer
on did Cody Bates died when he was with
you was it afterwards other Antonis
Bates
well the reason I made him my right-hand
man and head of the security team was
cuz he didn't get high so me and my all
my friends are running around like
lunatics on these club drug cocktails
and he's babysitting people taking
people home making sure nobody's odine
and stuff like that when I first met him
he was suicidal and we were like family
so when we all got sent down he went
back into that suicidal depression got
on heroin self-medicating his family
sent him to a rehab run by
Scientologists
they put him on a drug that had a side
effects of suicide and hung himself at
the Scientology Center yeah himself I
wrote a book partytime about all of that
and the publisher Random House made me
contact absolutely everybody have them
sign legal papers to say it was accurate
and they wouldn't sue me and they
wouldn't sue the publisher and what I
did was I interviewed all these people
on skype recorded the conversations and
there's so much more information I've
forgotten because I was so high that I
was able to put into the book what was
the event that led you to go into prison
I'd actually quit the importation of
ecstasy a year before the SWAT team came
I've been married three times I've met
another woman she taught me out of it
and because things were getting so heavy
as well she was late look this is really
risky now it's dangerous the New Mexican
Mafia guys they'd all got federal SWAT
team raided I was almost at the house as
the feds came I was just dropping one of
the guys off actually what I got caught
up in that Sammy the balls crew got
taken down in the beginning I'm thinking
thanks carps you've took out the
competition I should have been thinking
it's going to be me next but the drug
scrambles your decision-making processes
it's telling you you'd get away of
anything this woman talked some sense
into me and it was almost a year later I
thought I'd got away with him I never
got caught doing a big drug transaction
never got caught speaking about a big
drug transaction on the phone never even
got caught of any drugs what statute of
limitations in Arizona is seven years so
I had to accept my karma cheerfully ten
witness statements came forward and SWAT
team came may 16 2002 how was that so I
was back to stock trading online I was
enrolled in poly were bad yeah I was
that relevant normal life of this woman
yeah I'm stock trading online I'm
enrolled in a Spanish classes at college
I'm up early in the morning because
Arizona time New York time stock markets
open hmm all of a sudden boots thudding
up the stairs of the apartment bang so I
jump up look through the peephole it's
blacked out
I'm thinking is it someone coming to rob
me posing as the police just found out
or is it really the police go to the
window police cars all over the place
marks
rifles more boots coming up the stairs
girl fruits of the bedroom to my missus
what we gonna do better let them in half
way forget it just just this door just
flies off the hinges
hands above your head don't move get on
the ground now so you see all those guns
open up in front of you yeah ha almost
at my heart speeding of us feel the
sweat coming on the hearts your souls
reliving it right now
you see those guns and your thinking
your life is open in seconds if they
opened up right now and they're looking
at you like they want to put one in you
so you just drop down real fast and they
crush you and the detective then I said
the crush does the detective just yank
me up by the cuffs and he was like
English Shawn you're a big name from the
rave scene we finally got you
I'm sure this raid he's gonna get you
big charges and he's just talking he'll
[ __ ] at me yeah I could have a nemesis
in law enforcement yeah so what happens
next
so I'm thinking hey you know I'm bi I
don't understand the statute of
limitations at this point I do
understand some things that the New
Mexican Mafia schooled me on and they I
got the lawyer that they recommended so
I'm thinking there's no drugs they've
not caught me speaking about drugs
because I banned you know I wouldn't
talk on phones or anything over the
years what can they do
I'm AAV thinking they're gonna say well
there was no drugs there's no charges
we'll let him go but they slapped on me
you familiar the Takashi six nine
situation quit now it was the Arizona
State equivalent of Rico so now I've got
conspiracy continuous criminal
enterprise crime syndicate all these
charges and I'm not versed enough in law
to understand what they mean it became
apparent and that because all my money
was seized
I had full all money people over from
England put money in their names and the
police had put a virus in my computer
netbooks Trojan horses show me where all
the money was so they took absolutely
everything you or the people you've
flown from UK they took that the money
that was in their names
everything Wow yeah yeah it was a
multi-agency investigation
had software engineers from Washington
doing all this stuff with white stuff in
my computer I had to call my parents
and say look I need money rely and that
was you know I'd structured it so if I
got arrested my friends would bail me
out they had money
cops outsmarted me they arrested all of
us together so we have nobody to call
but your parents how was that phone call
like column I mean yet there's one of
the lowest points of my life just to
hear the heartbreaking their voices to
hear to feel how sick they're feeling
that the son it was a child protege
stock market guy they come over and
visited my million dollar house and I
told them I was doing all stock trading
it's after the light look here's what's
gone down and you know if I don't get
money basically I'm probably never going
to get home because I got to the point
was facing a 200 year maximum sentence
you get two hundred year maximum
sentence
yeah Wow and similar to you're saying
with Takashi's because he got fifty
they're talking 50 you got 200 yeah
there's a lot of people on YouTube right
now talking about Takashi and they have
no idea what they're talking about
even the hip-hop channels they're saying
is his trials gonna be next year in
September he's gonna get at least the
minimum 30 years because that's his
minimum the justice system is completely
Alice in Wonderland
those figures mean nothing what will
happen is the prosecutor over time will
plea bargain with these guys it won't
even go to trial that trial date if it
you know it's probably gonna get moved
multiple times they'll be in court every
month filing motions each side going
back and forth and you don't have to
snitch in my case what we did I met an
old-timer who was doing life and he said
look get a good lawyer and do what's
called a united front so in my case at
over a hundred people arrested with me
only four agreed to cooperate we had a
united front under Alan Simpson
it was the lawyer that the New Mexican
Mafia had represented and Sammy the
balls case 57 people were arrested
approximately all agreed to testify yeah
so I think because we had this United
Front
hardly anybody's
it really frustrated the prosecutor over
26 months they pulled up every dirty
trick in the book on me they I mean I
was at the point where I was about to
kill myself in the jail he got so rough
but at the end at the end of the day me
I was the head of the crime syndicate
wildwoman was number two while Wildman's
what woman out of the real wild man was
number three and none of us got more
than ten years so I thought that was at
the end of the day that was really good
because of the loophole my lawyer got as
a first-time nonviolent drug offender
non-uk US citizen I ended up serving
just under six years just so what would
your saying is you think some other
things gonna happen with Takashi's 16
yeah what will happen with Takashi 6-9
right now the prosecutor will have
organized the criminal organization the
crime syndicate in level of importance
so maybe Takashi will be be on the
shotty maybe shut he will be a or maybe
it will be the other way around just cuz
they want to get to Kashi because he's
the big headline that will enhance their
careers so they will then say to
everybody like effort and K and L
they'll say to FK and L look you guys
are small down here you're facing life
sentence is you're all co-conspirators
you all go down for each of those crimes
you guys testify against these guys and
we'll let you do time served that's
generally what bill say and that's what
they were saying in my case now they've
separated to Kashi six nine there's all
this speculation saying he snitched
already he's gone to prison for snitches
none of that is verified I think it's
far too early
probably for any of these guys to just
just just roll over in a prosecutor shot
he's obviously worried about it because
in court he's yelling now don't fall
don't bend in front of the judge which
is a really bad idea that's not a good
strategy I had a situation like that
happen in my own case now if you're
forming a united from how are you gonna
get word for the prison system to your
core defense not to snitch
well they've separated to Kashi so it
looks like you snitch in so
psychologically that will work bad
against the other co-defendants but you
can get what's called
kites these are letters sent by trustees
throughout the jail system we will send
a letter from Takashi in this prison
over to that prison those religious
services my guys we heard the whole two
back rolls of the religion
services we will all give each other our
hugs and I update them on all the legal
news the other thing is if the cache is
in a separate prison when he goes to
court with his co-defendants they're
gonna be in a row of holding cells right
outside of the courtroom kites can be
passed from some sell-through trustees
they think they can stay tight they can
get the word out that they're doing a
united front
Takashi's got the money to get such a
high-priced lawyer to fight back these
low-level guys are thinking right we've
got no money
we've got scammed scumbag public
defenders who just want us to sign plea
bargains these guys have got the money
to get the high-priced lawyers they're
just gonna let us end up getting you
know we're gonna have no legal
representation but - cashy right now
needs to get the word out we're doing a
united front and paying for a
high-priced lawyer I'm not snitching and
hope that everybody stays tight because
once people start to snitch then the
sentence will go up for the people who
are highest in the organization so what
happens walk us through you're going to
prison how was that like I mean who who
are you what prison did you go to what
level can I get a little bitter that's
all right so because I hadn't cooperated
prosecutor they pulled out every dirty
trick in the book so my first year in
the jail I've got this United Front
telling everyone not to agree so the
prosecutors like how can we get him away
from his co-defendants let's get him
over to maximum security because all my
co-defendants on minimum medium-security
now how she did that she knew I was
applying to get my bail reduced my bail
was $750,000 cash only she sabotaged the
bail hearing very crafty these
prosecutors she filed additional charges
and with an additional seven hundred
fifty thousand dollar bail so the judge
not did he not only reduce my bail he
maintained my original bail accepted the
new bail which made my total bail 1.5
million when you bail goes over a
million you're automatically
reclassified to maximum security autumn
so that's the guideline yeah so that's
how I ended up my second year in maximum
security now by the end of that they
tell that's where they're telling me
like like you're going to get 200 years
because every time you spoke about drugs
on the foil and carries five to ten
years and this isn't deals this is just
personal small stuff if we go to trial
lose we could stack that up to a maximum
200 year sentence and they made it clear
there was a guy before me a two-hour to
son a dealer he had a similar case he
refused to sign a plea bargain for 15
years and they gave it he went to trial
he gave him two hundred two hundred
years two hundred every charge carried
ten years maximum and they stacked all
of his charges they they didn't run them
concurrently they run them consecutively
the justice system is a business model
if you got a trial it cost the state
hundreds of thousands millions they want
everyone to sign a plea bargain and go
over to the prison system just about
down 98% of the cases go to plea bargain
that's it in Arizona name only only 2%
exercise their rights with trial if
everybody exercised the right to trial
the system would collapse it couldn't
afford to do all the trial got it
so that's how I ended up in the highest
security levels because the prosecutor
just have had it in for us because we
wouldn't we wouldn't cooperate like some
eatables people and so that kind of
didn't favor you because they were
hoping you would they were hoping that
we would lay that they thought we
weren't cuz some eatables people all did
they couldn't understand why we were so
tight but what happened was over the
years you know I knew these known these
guys for years I've grown up with some
of them people were scared of Wildman in
the New Mexico mafia guys it was you
know we were just all this in in the
jail be one of the biggest groups in the
jail well everybody went we're all
hugging each other and updating each
other and I've been even people that
didn't know me the prosecutor had what
was getting him to sign exhibit a people
in my case that I didn't know saying you
bought your drugs from outward you were
working for that word because then
prosecutor just makes the fault they
don't care they've got nothing to lose
they've got absolute immunity so
whatever they say they portray people
and doing things a lot of time that
legal paperwork it's utter [ __ ]
because they just want to put you in the
worst light they made me out to be the
Antichrist so they've got all these
people who don't even know me sign in
Exhibit A one guy Chicano gang member he
was in court will exhibit any says the
judge like Your Honor I have no idea who
Edward is and the prosecutors telling me
is it's a sign it's like yeah so you're
in prison
what do you you've never been in prison
before I'm assuming this is your first
time yeah so what what are you thinking
like who do I team up with oh my god who
do I go to who do I associate myself
saying Shawshank
so you go in there and it's all racially
divided and it's the whites the blacks
the mexican-americans so right away some
skinheads from the neo-nazi Aryan
Brotherhood come up to me hey we want a
word with you getting that cell over
there because I have been put in tower
six I wasn't with my co-defendants at
this point in time so I go into the cell
close the door behind me
biggest one gets in my face he's like
what are you charges
what are you charges now I mentioned my
charges to you I said earlier I didn't
understand what all that meant
conspiracy and everything so I said to
my don't understand what my charges mean
but isn't a good answer now how they
think I've got something to hide so they
got me up against the wall about to
smash me what do you mean you don't know
what your charge is meaning you a chomo
you a chomo I don't even know what a
channel is it at this point so much
child molester hmm yeah so I pulled out
my charge sheet they saw him for drugs
but the main business of the gang is
selling drugs to the prisoners so they
loved that they saw my bail was $750,000
they were like damn you guys the Mafia
who did you guys kill and I was like no
just raves ecstasy then they explained
the rules you got to follow if someone
calls you a punk a [ __ ] or hit you
fight him on the spot the whole gang
will smash you most take showers they'll
smash you for bad hygiene can't go and
make you friends with the guards they'll
smash you for snitching car said the
tables of the other races they'll smash
you for that and so on and so on
yeah just giving you the lowdown Oh give
me your lowdown right away you sit the
wrong place it's all over yeah but it
wouldn't mean by then it's all over if
you say you sit with the other races off
you go to the whites
table and sit on like the head dude see
cuz you just think you're getting your
lunch and that is how it works you're
gonna get your head smashed into a
toilet yeah just like that
I had to get too used to the sounds a
heads getting bashed against toilets and
bodies getting thrown around so who did
you go with at that point like you've
got no choice they tell you this is how
it works you're white you know if we
have a meeting you come to the white boy
meeting you sit with the whites
you in your cell he's supposed to have
white cell mates now white white sir
nad white-supremacist this is just white
this is the Aryan Brotherhood prison
gang they got it they've got the
swastikas they got the lightning bolts
they got the warbirds yeah wait wait
they completely control the prison
system for the white race were you
required to get any of the tattoo is in
there to someone else they you rose to
represent there's only few actual
equivalent to made men gang members shot
callers and probate and to join the
Aryan Brotherhood for example the
probates God I had to collect a debt
beat someone up
get your SS lightning bolts get your
Swasey tuff be a full member you got to
murder someone in the jail for them oh
you have to murder someone get a full
yeah guys so who when you were in you
were in how many different types of
prisons Wow over the course of this
whole thing I was in to remand jails and
then in the Arizona Department that was
my first 26 months and then over the
Arizona Department of Corrections about
four or five different prisons and then
I finally a deportation facility now I
actually did time in super
maximum-security where I wasn't supposed
to be and that was because the
prosecutor final farewell just to mess
with me after I was sentenced she
accidentally put mice nine and a half
year sentence down as 34 years on the
paperwork to the prison system you're
nine and a half to accidently she did it
she put it on a story for just to mess
with me so I got fast-track to Supermax
how was that well looking back now I'm
glad that she did all this stuff cuz
it's created a more extreme story so
Supermax my cellmate was he had like a
pentagram tattooed on his forehead part
of a cult list doing drinking blood and
doing human sacrifice yeah yeah this is
who you ran in with this is in super
Mexico super high security is killers
serial killers death row shits lingers
there's a whole row of [ __ ] slingers
because you can't settle your disputes
in Supermax oh yeah this because you're
locked in your cell they weaponize crap
so the basic method of that is a chicken
bone
below pipe crap on the chicken bone
you're going past the cell they dart you
chicken bone gets into your blood system
your blood circulates the crap
throughout your your damages your immune
system and two-thirds of these guys have
got hepatitis C just from sharing dirty
needles that's the basic method the
Rambo of the shits lingers was this guy
called Magnum and he would let the [ __ ]
piss concoction he would leave it for
days until mold grew on it and he rigged
his cell up with like crap Aziz it make
shampoo bottles into bazookas with tubes
on them and then when a guard goes past
audit the staff replies yeah I got our
aura a prisoner he just opened fire on
them and they came in they stripped him
out took everything out of his cell put
him in a dry cell naked handcuffed and
they figured that was it he wasn't gonna
be able to get them that day they'd
underestimated his resolve magnums stood
at the front of that cell was molten
crap in his mouth and when the guard
came and malt and Magnum Unleashed the
molten crap the guard was so surprised
and shocked he raised his mask up and
some of the crap went up his nose yeah
yeah so you've seen some interesting
things at the super maximum weight how
long was it how long were you at the
super maximum I was in the Supermax and
about three or four months before my
sentence got fixed by my lawyer to what
it should have been in the first place
so Shan how many different levels are
there in prison system in every up in
every security level from Supermax the
minimum how many are the levels from the
minimum to Supermax it depends on
whether it's federal or state and how
many prisons the system has got so there
might be like and the UK is different
from the US but in general this is a
generalization you could say there's
minimum medium maximum super maximum but
there's all kinds of other types of
facilities as well such as lock downs
and things like that got it yeah so when
you're in prison I mean I'm I'm hearing
there's access to everything you can buy
drugs you can buy steroids you have
phones you can buy what was the biggest
commodity what was the most expensive
drugs and that was what causes the most
violence and death and murder the
illegal marketing drugs the estimates
were four trillion dollars a year right
now that has corrupted everything it
comes into contact with including the
prison system mm-hmm when you go start
arresting people who mostly got
addiction issues a lot of my friends in
prison were Marines come back from wars
PTSD got on the street drugs ended up in
prison the highest arrest category back
then when I was arrested was weed
possession Wow a million arrests a year
almost a weed possession million a year
and they come to prison and graduate to
heroin and crystal meth so the absolute
priority of the drug gang is this you've
got this ideal target market place of a
mix so guards are smuggling drugs in for
the gangs nurse was arrested bringing
drugs in for the Mexican Mafia while I
was there drugs are getting dropped off
in drones these days visitors are
bringing drugs to visitation in the
lowest security levels there is more
drugs in prison than anywhere on the
face of the earth but dealers in prison
are boasting that they're making more
money inside than they were selling
drugs before they were arrests where
they keep the money where they keep the
cash it's a street-to-street oh got it
yeah
so say your mydlink yes and I'm a
customer yeah your woman outside goes
and pays my woman outside of visits you
know cash is exchanged I got it yeah and
it's still taking place street to stream
and so hoping when I come out I have
some cash sitting around that's waiting
for me if you're not super done if
you're an entrepreneur yeah that makes
sense
you're in you had some dealings with the
Mexican Mafia but the Mexican Mafia
connection for you wasn't in prison that
happened prior to that I know right
and how close did you get with them all
right so I mentioned wild man's first
visit yes wellman opened a lot of doors
for me because like I mentioned about my
anxiety stuff he wherever he goes people
take notice he's 25 26 phone trying to
think what the American a [ __ ] that
is now maybe like 250 300 pounds he's
knows he's pointing over his fist to
twice the size of mine it's just got all
human teeth marks all over his knuckles
so at these apartment parties we were
throwing in the early XE days he'd have
like Russian mobsters coming up Mexican
gangsters coming over
agender Native Americans Street
gangbangers just as a collective Mack
electic mix of people and that's how I
got to meet all these different people
now at one of these apartment parties I
was applying the ecstasy and there's
ruggedly handsome Mexican American guy
shows up with long dark prison tattoos
on his arms and he's supplying the coke
and the weed
so as we're both the suppliers we start
chilling and talking and a Tempe police
man walks in he goes I could smell we've
mount side nobody move
so gdug the Mexican American guy's name
is and I've never seen anything like
this before
just whips out he's gone points at the
cops head says the only one who's not
leaving is you [ __ ] everybody
run so I'm like holy [ __ ] you know I'm
just like [ __ ] we're all gonna get
arrested now I've got drugs on me so we
all we all just ran off into the night
basically now this was a huge apartment
complex called Rancho Murieta in Tempe
Arizona it's got all these other
buildings and as part of my organization
when I had people in apartments we would
structure apartment complexes so like
the drugs are here the cash is here in
the apartment and protection is over
here in North partment so if anything
went off we could move everything around
but legally so we I went up it's one of
these other apartments and all hell's
breaking loose now please sirens and so
we're all in there thinking cops are
gonna come should we flush our stuff
next thing bang bang on the French
window is it the cops we open the French
window it's G dog he's like let me in so
he says the police haven't got a warrant
he schooled us they can't come in
without a warrant they haven't seen me
coming here turn the lights off
everybody shut the table nobody move
if they come just don't open the door mm
so we were debating when we were over to
flush the drugs and he's like don't
sweat it so he was right the cops came
and they were knocking on the door
we didn't answer they went next door
they went all over the complex and at
the end of the night I said to him look
because you're so hot here why don't you
come over to a house I've got in FINA
so that's what what we didn't he stayed
there and then he said Shawn because you
and your friends had my back me and my
brothers have got your back I had no
idea what that meant so a couple months
later cuz my brother wants to meet you
so I go over to this street in Tempe the
goalies lowrider fancy show cars on the
street go to the front door
his brothers like shot guy know her wife
beater on shots down to here just
looking to [ __ ] me with this mean face
then he hears me speaking he's like damn
you talk funny homie it's like I guess
you are from England come through meet
my homeys so I go into the living room
with G dog and there's all these massive
tattooed Mexican American guys got the
chains on they're looking at me like
they want to eat me you know who is this
guy
they've got like guns aks
mini machine guns slabs of crystal meth
slabs of cocaine weighing scales I'm
looking around the room see the biggest
TV I've ever seen they've got a little
screen watching all the comings and
goings on the street like holy [ __ ]
that's not on I saw it and a Rambo movie
rocket-propelled grenade launcher on the
TV yeah so I'm thinking these guys are
heavy-duty and I was always nervous
every time I went over the jet from one
time they said look I women too coming
over and we're gonna have an ecstasy
party we're gonna try your stuff out so
I went over the Oh going back to the
first time one of them actually swung we
spoonful of coke in my face that first
time and he's like snort this and I'm
walking over Jews like yes that's it
just to see if I was a cop you know and
that guy I won't say his name but when I
did learn who they were that guy was
actually a hitman who done quite was
putting in quite a lot of work at that
point in time yeah
so they say we're having this ecstasy
party and I go over in the night because
they've run out of pills and they're all
an ecstasy for the first time but these
guys when I got over there like these
big sweaty overgrown teddy bears picking
me up
bugging me England man we love your
pills trying to tell me their life
stories but every time I went over there
after there
it was back to that lethal atmosphere
now the only way I learned who they was
was because years later I was dropping
gdug off one night and the whole
neighborhood was blacked out
the police were out with light ones
guiding trending as we pull up to the
house
federal SWAT team are bringing all these
guys out in handcuffs and we just kept
going and it was news headlines that
they knew Mexican Mafia most powerful
violent criminal and organization in
Arizona they tried to assassinate the
head of the Department of Corrections
the prison system they were taking out
witnesses please all kinds so the good
thing that came about was my debts are
in the hundreds of thousands and people
knew I was click that with them and the
money started to come in a little bit
faster yeah so that was your experience
with the make which which one of the
which one of the gangs in prison were
the most feared okay I mean it varies
probably prison by prison from your
experience in prison what happens is the
numbers with the most pics on the
numbers with the least it's a shame
because well I say it's a shame but from
a power-play move the Chicanos the
Mexican Americans and the Mexicans they
would be the biggest but they're at war
in the Arizona prison system yeah
they've been at war since the 1990s if
they were united they would every night
they'd be the biggest where I was housed
in medium security in the beginning I
would say it was the Mexicans Mexican
Americans slightly over half then the
whites then the blacks less than a
quarter and the Native Americans and
others fraction in America we u.s. is
roughly four point four percent of the
world population is what US has right
but they have 22% of world's prisoners
so four point four percent world
population 22% prisoners and when you
study their stats
nineteen fifty per hundred thousand we
had a hundred and fifty prisoners per
hundred thousand fifty today that
numbers around seven hundred and over a
half if T percent of the prisoners
today are in because of drug charges
that's what changed the war against
drugs you know when you were in did you
see some guys we're like that just
doesn't belong in here you know he he
should go in a different route and do
you think sometimes the association of a
guy that got him for weed or something
like that being around others he learned
other bad habits that when he got out he
brought that you know habit into the
streets what are your thoughts have
experience with that but mass
incarceration of low-level drug users is
incentivized by a conspiracy between
politicians legislators the private
prisons and all of the other predatory
contractors making money off this so the
media puts out these headlines saying
prisons are for murderers rapists
pedophiles and drug traffickers like
Pablo Escobar and on the other side they
say how easy prison is to keep a public
hating on prisoners what the average
arrest was a black kid or a Mexican kid
with a bit of weed getting a 2 to 5 year
sentence and what I saw and so what did
you meet kids in prison where you're
looking and when I say kids average
arrests yeah yeah so what are you like
why are you in what is this a full of
these people almost a million arrests a
year for weed possession in America at
the height of the war on drugs let me
ask you having experienced different
levels what would you suggest what would
you cuz in the in UK you guys are all
like 125 per 100,000 it's different
where the highest incarceration rate in
Europe because the same political
private prison influences are corrupting
our system here they tried to open the
biggest kid's prison in the Western
world in this country last year the
prison was going to get a hundred
thousand dollars plus per year of
taxpayers money per kid they asked to
make half of young people experiment
with drugs they can fill it up with
young kids on drugs all day long it went
to House of Lords and Lord said is this
something we're gonna be proud of and
they shut it down they shut it the
politicians and the corporation's are
still trying to get it pushed through so
so there's there's a battle there right
one is somebody's watching this they're
saying oh my gosh but he you know you
you gave ecstasy to people you're a drug
dealer you you know you have a lot of
kids that you taught and taught them a
lot of bad habits you know and you you
you hurt some families that's what you
did
okay fine and then there are those
people that will say yeah but let's just
say guy that's doing which should he be
going to prison what should it's not
fair for him to go to
but we got to keep the drug dealers off
the street the balance of it how do you
balance that up for somebody that's seen
this yourself I write about the war on
drugs people like Pablo Escobar Cali
cartel America made things like that so
I've researched this thoroughly you've
raised a few separate points there I
take full responsibility for I did I
deserve to be punished I got off lightly
by having a high-priced lawyer and doing
a united front defense I learned a lot
of lessons in prison I'm actually the
poster child for it but Arizona's got
the highest incarceration and highest
reoffending according to FBI stats some
of the highest in the country you tell
my recent division tap of stats yeah I'm
talking about FBI stats
yeah over the years that I've looked at
what is the purpose of prisons in the
police the police were started out of
London by Robert Peel if you look how
crime has been defined for millennia
murder robbery rape drug traffickers
like myself not excusing that person a
murders rapes robs person B mm-hmm
there's always a victim mm-hmm when they
ramped up the war on drugs and said who
the easiest people to arrest kids with
weed when you arrest the kid with weed
who's that person hurting himself yeah
so the whole purpose of the police which
was to take person a out of society that
hurts hurts person B has been subverted
by the war on drugs a kid with weed is
hurtin themselves maybe their family
that's a cry for help that kids need
mentorship that kid may need some mental
health counseling that kid needs
encouragement in life and what do we do
with them we put them in a place where
they're going to get indoctrinated by a
neo-nazi gang who idolize getting Hitler
tattoos and swastikas and you got a
murder someone to be a full member and
you're gonna make your criminal
connections and they're gonna give you a
swastika on your forehead so when you
get out and go for a job interview you
can't get a job you're gonna come right
back to the game and the jail is gonna
say hey if we educate these people if we
give them the high school diplomas when
they get out they're gonna stand a
chance in life
no let's allow it to be drug and gang
infested mayhem because when they get
out we'll give them fifty dollars gate
money say have a nice day
they're gonna go right back to crime
because it's drunk drug and gang
infested man yeah yeah and when they get
arrested
$50,000 of taxpayers money per year
right back to the jail or the prison I
think it's up to 70,000 now I'm just
quoting figures when I got arrested the
racket on the tax base shakedown I see
that so the percentage that I saw is
after one year 56% 56% of prisoners make
it back in yeah three years is 67
percent five years is 76 percent so once
you go in there's a very high likelihood
of you getting back in within the next
one three five years Corrections
Corporation are boasting in the annual
reports that shareholders our profit
growth is guaranteed because they keep
coming back they're not correcting
people they're breaking them so Shawn
let me ask you two people if you're
speaking to somebody right now a kid
who's 22 years old yeah
messing around with stuff selling weed
selling coke selling ecstasy selling
whatever it is he's selling on the
streets what do you tell someone like
that because when you're in it sometimes
you know I remember when I was coming up
I was doing my own version of things and
you almost feel like you're not infamous
untouchable like I can get away I can
outsmart the system right what would you
say to somebody that's in that moment
saying you know I'm gonna be able to get
away he got caught but I'm not gonna get
caught I felt like I was above the law
and the drugs was telling me that we
were joking we're above the law were
living in the movie drug scrambles your
decision-making process is you're not
thinking normally or surrounded myself
with equally crazy people reinforcing
each other's insane behavior I would say
to those kids do these prisons and these
politicians the contract in the tens of
billions they want you out doing drugs
they look at you as suckers to arrest
because they know they're going to get
you in Chile and make money off your
back now what I didn't understand is the
road of drug use is very long the
pleasures extremely high in the
beginning in the pain is low you don't
see what's coming at you down that road
and young person because the the
pleasure is so high you're always
chasing the early high but you never get
it back so you make sure drugs up are
you move on to harder drugs over time in
the background the pain is slowly
anything and when it crosses if you're
addicted you can't stop I only learnt
this in the jail it made me ashamed of
putting people on that road I knew I
couldn't change my path so I my main
thing is now he's telling school kids my
story so they won't do what I did but in
the jail I saw the horror of what drug
use led to 90% sure not my heroin
crystal meth 2/3 hepatitis C 9 the 90%
yellow jaundice skin teeth rotting out
and I thought to myself I popping up
people on that road you know actually I
should be ashamed now to treat all those
guys with hepatitis C interferon 30,000
a year would bankrupt the system so they
say to them you know you're not getting
the treatment some sue in court they've
got money other got legal skills and it
takes years just to get the treatment
and by then the liver it might have
advanced and that they made it bit can
even be saved anyway some of them would
win the treatment after this big court
battle and the final hurdle was right
congratulations you've won your
treatment treatment doesn't work unless
you stop the drugs now you got to stop
the drugs and some of the girls guys
were so addicted they would keep doing
the drugs and choose to die rather than
save their own lives that is the power
of addiction so my point here is young
people think about what's gonna come at
you down that road I was given a front
row seat and it's an absolute horror
show now if you've got an addictive
personality like me there's nothing
wrong with channeling that energy into
positive atoms so I put it know I do
karate
I do body combat yoga and meditation
really got my anxiety down save my
sanity interesting yeah yeah when's the
last time you touched drugs I didn't
touch drugs since I got arrested
yeah Oh since you got arrested you
haven't touched stopped it yeah Wow yeah
and so and so let me ask you you haven't
been in since you got out no what did
you do to make sure you didn't get in
because you know it's very easy to come
to UK and maybe use some of those habits
here because your crime was in Arizona
you can start a new thing over here how
come you didn't do various factors
stopped me going back I read over a
thousand books and just on the six years
a lot of philosophy in psychology and
they enabled me to go deep inside myself
and address the root causes and not to
go back to it the therapist said if you
give something up and it
fiction even if it's a negative one
there's a space inside you and you've
got to fill it mmm don't replace it
karate body combat exercise yoga these
things they keep me level-headed I still
go out and dance my ass off all night at
some of these clubs like ministry should
check ministry out while you're here or
some of the gay bars of Clapham Common
where they got the hands in the air
dance moves yeah I just closed my eyes
get into the vibe and dance to feel
those endorphins cascading physical
movement causes the brain to release the
chemicals being dolphins to cascade you
don't have to be doing these other
things it's just it's just a shot core
physical activity can get you sports is
a great one for young people I advocate
yeah so you you replaced a bad habit
with something else as which it is what
does I got yeah so so you know and I
know you give away a lot of books
nowadays you you're yeah you're in the
business of giving away books I do
public events on a vessel on Amazon I've
got almost ten books oh well life
stories party time
hard time prison time and from the
profits from my sales at my public
events I donate books to kids in state
schools and to prisoners and in the last
three years now I've managed to donate
twenty thousand books do yoga believe in
karma all these kind blog readers sent
me books from all over the world because
my writing was smuggled out the jail it
went on to attract international media
attention all these kind people who's
like a real Shawshank Redemption moment
we're filling the prison library up so I
give back now to these kids and these
prisoners in the hope that reading will
help them in their journey and in a last
question I'll ask you as we address that
a little bit I'm curious to know what
you're gonna say obviously you you've
thought about this I'm in the financial
industry so for me everything within the
industry I have to study because I'm in
that space I mean short space the good
bad and the ugly what would be the
solution like what would really be the
solution to not have some of these petty
crimes that people are doing to put them
in prison do you separate petty crime
you know petty criminals in different
prison do you put him through a 90-day
probationary school kind of system where
you're on lockdown
what would your suggestion be I say this
and the UK to people we shouldn't be
following the American
we should be following the countries
that are closing prisons down right now
because of the guts per capacity so
petty crime like I said it's low-level
drug use should that even be a crime
these people need help
Portugal had over a hundred thousand
heroin addicts they were following the
American model he said this is not
working anymore
let's legalize let's decriminalize let's
see what happens
the police said if you do that what kind
of examples it sets a young people
decriminalizing heroin there'll be
people doing this all over the streets
what actually happened was the addicts
were no longer afraid of getting
arrested they talked to the health teams
who counseled them and Portugal more
than half the heroin addicts of all of
the types of drug users heroin is a
miniscule amount of drug use but
disproportionately it causes the most
petty crime shoplifting burglaries which
isn't petty crime it's more serious and
an acquisitive crime it causes the
majority of it when you legalized and
decriminalized because it doesn't cost
most much give these guys medicinal
grade
opium is just a plant that cost hardly
anything doesn't cost the taxpayer much
then they don't have to go out stealing
are they so the petty crime around it
collapsed as well and the transmission
of diseases from sharing dirty needles
it would be interesting cuz you know
when you go to Alcatraz the first thing
they do when you go to San Francisco I
don't know if you've been they show you
the stats here's how many people have
done this here's how many people are in
prison here's how many inmates we have
here's what's going on with this here's
what's going on with America here's
where Marco ranks I think number one in
a number two is Russia and then you see
the stats going down yeah I don't know
if America's figured out the perfect
solution on how to do this I saw there's
a 76 billion dollar-a-year number that
we spend for prisons and this is a 2011
stat is what I saw I don't know if we
figured out the way but I do believe
that there needs to be major adjustments
being made because the direction we're
going in the current status one in 20
Americans will at one point go to prison
yeah one in twenty that's a pretty big
number to have one in 20 go to prison
yeah so either you know it doesn't need
to be
that many going or there needs to be a
better step process one two three on
what happens and how you go to it what
are your thoughts on that America does
have it figured out exactly where it
wants it this is all school money they
don't want any changes they want to be
profits in tens of billions a year in
contracts of this private prison system
that's just the private prisons include
the prison guard unions includes the
lawyers include all of the contractors
of the prisons there's like a pipeline
to prison program in America now to
enhance this catch the kids judges the
old money wants to maintain this US
federal government has got weed as a
Schedule one substance more harmful than
crystal meth and cocaine with no
medicinal value whatsoever because
that's what maximizes corporate profits
they're not interested in the welfare of
these young people are getting tossed
into into these prisons there's people
doing 25 to life for joints of weed on
the three-strikes laws there's people
doing it for peat stealing pizzas 25 to
life in California they tried to repeal
the three strikes law in California
25 to life is stealing a pizza guy was
doing 50,000 a year 1.25 million for ten
dollar pizza why are we the taxpayers of
California paying for this when it went
to get repealed people who put money up
put money up to get it introduced stop
it getting repealed prison guards Union
of California Broadcom exclusive
provider of telephone services to the
California state prison system the
taxpayers money is a feeding trough to
the corporation's to these parasites the
conte the political contributions to the
legislators and the politicians coming
down are in the tens of millions why
change that it's just one big money go
around by a select group of people but
what's happened is the American people
are sick of it at the state level you
guys are now voting to legalized and
decriminalized weed that's not the u.s.
federal government that's the people the
people over there are sick of their kids
getting from these prisons where they
just graduate to harder crime the sick
at their kids who're having the seizures
can't get the cannabis oil going into
comas and dying all these evil
politicians who have maintained this for
years have caused all these kids to die
over the years we couldn't get their
medicine but when you now produce a kid
the internet and technology is making
all this word spread so fast these evil
politicians can't go up against these
dying kids and that's how it's falling
and falling at the state level and
that's the hope I think the floodgate is
open now and the whole thing is gonna
collapse yeah that's what you foresee
taken absolutely yeah yeah interesting
yeah shot final thoughts for you what
are your final thoughts you have if you
were to say here's my experiences here's
what I've learned here's what I suggest
what would you say I'd like to say to
the fellas in prison especially and
entrepreneurs outside I've seen
parallels in both worlds hmm you know as
a best-selling author for now on Amazon
I've got to have a good product I've got
to know how to market my product I've
got have relations with the right people
if you're in prison because you were
running the drug business you've got all
those skills plus you're watching your
back avoiding the police doing all this
other stuff as well your skill set is
enhanced so I hope that people who see
me I've got out of prison become a
success story I hope that inspires them
to do well in the world as well what
book would you suggest the viewer to
read I think because of the way you've
structured it yes people have been most
interested in my years before I got
arrested and my jail time so that party
time is everything when I got arrested
my dealings with the mafia rising to the
ranks in the ecstasy world and then hard
time is first going into the GLS that
was the deadliest period of time for me
I've also got hundreds of questions
answered on my YouTube prison questions
playlist as well yeah you by the way he
has stuff that he talks about Pablo
Escobar you talk about how the callee
worked with you know the DEA to help
take out Pablo it's real interesting
things you talk about on your channel by
the way here's what I want you to do I
put the link for the books below for you
to go buy his books but if you got
anything you took away you got questions
for Shawn he's on Twitter I know you and
I were going back and forth yesterday on
Twitter send him a tweet or send me a
tweet based on what she took away from
this interview and if you got any
questions for him shoot the questions
over two minutes what would that being
said Shawn yeah thank you so much thank
you thanks for coming up